the suicide squad is the first dc film
from james gunn
and it's overflowing with darkly
disturbed heroes visually stunning
sequences and sizzling dialogue here's
some lines in the suicide squad that
mean more than you might have realized
the first time you heard them
when amanda waller introduces robert
dubois aka bloodsports these are the
bonafides that she chooses to highlight
on his resume
he's imprisoned for putting superman in
the icu with the kryptonite bullet
this line is three purposes first and
foremost it establishes that although
dubois doesn't have any superpowers he
possesses
a skill set formidable enough to take
down anyone even arguably the most
powerful hero in all of comicdom
secondly it tells us that this threat is
rooted in not only stellar marksmanship
but also his high-tech suit and weaponry
that manifests itself
ensuring that he always has the right
weapon for any given situation
the third purpose is to establish the
stakes for the film's biggest showdown
near the end of the film as jotunheim is
collapsing and peacemaker is moments
away from executing ratcatcher 2 dubois
comically surfs from floor to floor
each collapsing beneath him as he tries
to stay steady depositing him right into
the confrontation
realizing the situation peacemaker turns
his gun on bloodsport and if you don't
immediately know who's gonna win that
shootout you weren't listening very
closely to waller's introduction
each member is chosen for his or her own
completely unique set of abilities
another line from waller and this time
the director of argus seems to be
tipping off not only her own status as
puppet master but also a game plan that
stacks the deck against the majority of
task force x
most literally the line foreshadows a
comical bloody opening that kills off
several characters
why would waller choose blackguard
captain boomerang tdk javelin mongol and
savant to storm a beach filled with arm
to the t
soldiers none of these chosen fighters
are bulletproof or have powers that
could unarm the soldiers with a wave of
hand
they're a little more than baits on a
hook selected to make a whole bunch of
noise and not much
else it's also very hard to believe that
someone as thorough as waller would
select weasel and not know perfectly
well that he couldn't swim it's just a
distraction of course which is
interesting not only because waller
clearly wanted bloodsport peacemaker
king shark rat catcher 2 and polkadot
man to be her a team
but also because by placing colonel rick
flagg and harley quinn on her b
team was she hoping for them to also be
mowed down and hail of gunfire upon
reaching the shores of portal maltese
waller is surprised to learn that flags
survive the slaughter and doesn't seem
to have plans for harley quinn beyond
the beach either
so in essence that line is waller saying
everybody whose unique set of abilities
we need will be on the a-team
everybody chosen for useless powers that
will distract the enemy around the b
team and they'll make a big ruckus
before they die now if you were to ask
harley quinn after the events of the
movie she'd tell you that javelin did
serve a purpose
and that purpose was to give her the
weapon she would eventually need to stop
staro and save the day
we're all gonna die i hope so this early
moment from abner krill whose page-bound
predecessor james gunn endearingly
describes as the dumbest dc character of
all time
reminds us of what gun does better than
any modern filmmaker
take an idea that sounds terrible and
delicately transform it into something
audiences will love
by the end of the film polka dot man
will likely be your favorite suicide
squad member
also by the end of the film he will have
come a long way from the self-loathing
debbie downer wishing death upon himself
and his squad mates
krill has more issues than sports
illustrated to be sure chief among them
a deep hatred for the mother he
envisions as every enemy he hopes to
obliterate
but as the film goes on he finds true
joy through the mission and the
camaraderie therein
this particularly feels true with
polkadot man's moment on the dance floor
just before the team captures the
thinker when he seems to let his hair
down for the first time
another factor of growth seems to be a
genuine friendship with ratcatcher 2
who's also the most bothered by his
eventual fate when all is said and done
polkadot man is as into his job as any
of us in the audience who hope to live
vicariously through these characters
i'm a superhero
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no yeah it's a funny line yeah it's very
james gunn and yeah i got a big laugh in
the trailer but it's also a totally fake
moment
as we learned later in the film
peacemaker was the only member of the
suicide squad who
got the real briefing on this mission
with that knowledge how can this
exchange be seen as anything other than
a duplicitous attempt to establish
peacemaker as too
lunkheaded to have an ulterior motive he
already knows he's really going to corto
maltese to destroy files link in the us
to jotunheim and kill any of his
teammates who get in the way
he also likely knows that project
starfish refers to a giant space
starfish that has been experimented on
there for decades
of course this also means waller is
faking her frustration with his question
she knows quite well that peacemaker's
overzealous notetaking is a facade
one quite likely devised by her in
reality james gunn told cena on the set
to play the character like a broad up
version of captain america
by the end of the film it's clear that
peacemaker isn't this stupid
and also that he's arguably the most
villainous of all these villains
in the dc extended universe there is no
such thing as covet 19.
lucky then all they have to fear are
brain-sucking starfish child-murdering
weasels and walking sharks that might
mistake them for a num num
as all of us are well too aware the
suicide squad is among the many many
blockbuster films impacted by the
worldwide pandemic that put much of pop
culture on hold for good reason
beginning in 2020
much of the film was edited at the
writer director's home in the latter
half of 2020 as coronavirus forced many
people to work remotely
of course james gunn knows all this and
in his own sly way he wants to
acknowledge the elephant in the room
so on the verge of the climactic battle
in yotenheim when the squad briefs the
thinker on the rules of engagement
harley quinn plays
comic relief telling the mad scientist
which actions will get him killed
if you cough without covering your mouth
early hello that isn't an open
invitation for you to cough without
covering your mouth so if you plan to
see the suicide squad in theaters take
it from harley quinn and colonel flagg
and be mindful of germ spreading
wash your hands wear your mask where
applicable and try not to cough while
task force x are explaining the rules
because we all know now what happens to
the thinker and you definitely do
not want to end up like that guy check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
suicide squad are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you